ce dimanche on ne souligne pas seulement
la fête des pères mais c'est également
la journée nationale des peuples
autochtones une journée qui prend un
sens particulier cette année on en parle
avec michèle audette adjointe au
vice-recteur de l'université laval et
également la ex-commissaire de l'
enquête nationale sur les femmes
disparues et assassinées bonjour madame
odette bonjour à vous c'est quoi
l'importance de cette journée pour les
peuples autochtones dans les années 90
lorsque ça a été demandé le par mais
leadership autochtone c'était de
rappeler l'importance à tous les
canadiens canadiennes et les gens qui
nous écoutent
à cette époque-là de connaître la vraie
histoire l'histoire le côté noir de
l'histoire auquel on a vécu pendant trop
longtemps et aussi toutes les réussites
les célébrations et les grandes
victoires que les autochtones vont avoir
apporté ici là dans ce pays où qui
continue je dirais pour être plus
sincère de contribuer
alors se réconcilier avec un passé mais
aussi tendre la main pour faire de
belles choses aujourd'hui
le 10 est une journée qui prend tout a
un sens dans le contexte actuel bon
c'est parce que plusieurs choses des
manifestations on sait également
dernièrement dans le dernier mois il ya
eu deux autochtones qui ont été déçus
par des policiers au nouveau brunswick
la caq annoncé la mise sur pied d'un
groupe d'action sur le racisme un
travail que vous allez suivre de près
j'imagine de très près par ce que je
sais faire un parallèle avec le temps
qu'on a il ya quelques temps de cela le
même gouvernement d'avoir mis un comité
un groupe de travail de gens élus et de
nos mii pour regarder toute la violence
sexuelle envers les femmes ici au québec
une fois le rapport déposé ils vont
passer à l'action et on voit aujourd'hui
juripop de pouvoir bénéficier d'un
financement important pour soutenir
toutes les femmes qui ne connaissais pas
le système vous ne comprenez pas ce
thème suite à une agression sexuelle
alors là moi je me dis un précédent
intéressant donc oui je vais suivre de
près ce que les gens vont faire j'invite
les hommes et les femmes
allié à la cause autochtone et les
groupes autochtones de questionner
demandé des réponses vous faites ce
comité
cette semaine et d'un chef des premières
nations dont ghislain picard qui ont
joint leurs voix pour crier haut et fort
qu'ils veulent une action y met
dia partout au pays qui en ont assez des
rapports des commissions à répétition
est ce que vous êtes du même avis et je
le suis aussi le côté hybride pour moi
je pense que des actions immédiates ccc
fondamental c'est ce qu'on veut depuis
toujours mais faut toujours aussi garder
à l'esprit que comme outil de viry et
comme outil de mobilisation et pédagogie
muy les arcs est moins con avoir vécu
une 33 de façon intensive c'est
important bon il le racisme système etc
la discrimination envers les autochtones
on le voit au québec comme ailleurs au
pays qu'est ce que ça prend selon vous
pour faire évoluer et changer les
mentalités
eux c'est beaucoup d'endroits dans
lequel on doit faire un exercice de
conscience un changement une révision ou
carrément changer de sa frontière
c'est pas juste à un gouvernement si à
tous les milieux environnement beaucoup
plus tu vois par rapport à ça c'est de
faire en sorte que justice
voyons tout les appels de justice qu'on
a proposé on lui donne les actions elles
sont venues par des gens par des experts
par des familles par les survival livre
le complot voyons le rapport de vérité
réconciliation beaucoup d'outils qui
existe je pense à votre chien qui vous
êtes un peu importe on n'a pas brillé en
terminant tout un contexte de pandémie à
plusieurs initiatives virtuel pour
signer cette souligner cette journée
nationale des peuples autochtones ou
comment ça va se dérouler au pays à
travers le canada le réseau des centres
d'amitié autochtone on peut voir qu'ils
sont très très actif d'ailleurs je vous
quitte pour retourner avec un vidéo pour
celui de saguenay les communautés
autochtones dans l'histoire de nos
organisations politiques vont vous dire
ce qu'elles font qui est des spectacles
live le chanteur de temps à la mange
tous savent vraiment là important
d'aller voir ce qui se passe déjà qu'il
manque à la journée nationale n'est pas
présente au crâne de vienne
un jour férié au pays vous êtes de cet
avis qu'est ce que ça pourrait donner
bien peu pour moi pas pour voir si les
gens veulent un congé tant mieux pour
moi c'est un moment où je dois continuer
à faire cette pédagogie et d'éducation
populaire c'est d'aller célébrer et
d'aller faire l'éducation mais aussi de
souligner le tout ce qui s'est passé est
ce qu'on est aujourd'hui de nos
aspirations de dôme et donc pour moi je
rencontre tous les jours parce que ce
que je fais tout alors qu'ogier jaloux
dette merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous une excellente journée nationale
des peuples autochtones à vous et à
votre chien bonne journée chargée pour
vous au revoir